This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Rob.
And I'm Sam.
With the outbreak of the coronavirus epidemic, people in many countries around the world
have started wearing face masks to protect both themselves and others they come into contact with.
In this programme we'll be asking whether wearing masks in public can help prevent
the spread of coronavirus in the community.
Wearing a protective mask or face covering is nothing new. Medical masks have a long history
from the plagues of medieval Europe to 19th century outbreaks of cholera in the United States.
But when did they start to be commonly used? That's my question for today. When and where were
face masks first widely used? Was it A, 1855 in Vienna, B, 1905 in Chicago, or C, 1955 in London?
Hmm, well you mentioned cholera outbreaks in the US, Rob. So I'll say B, 1905 in Chicago.
Right, Sam. Where we'll find out later if you are right.
Now face masks may inspire confidence, but what is the evidence that they actually protect the
wearer from contracting the virus or prevent infected people from spreading the virus to others?
Professor Rob West has conducted a review of over 20 studies looking into the evidence.
Here he is speaking to the BBC World Service Programme Health Check.
The evidence is equivocal on it. It doesn't really tell you anything yet. I mean,
hopefully that will change. So we're thrown back on sort of first principles and basics and
this is why I've seen so many other areas of public health. You get such a heated debate because
people are really relying on their opinion on things and you will have one group who say,
well, it stands to reason. The good old stands to reason argument, which is obviously if you've
got a covering in front of your face and you're speaking or coughing into that covering, it's going
to trap quite a lot of the virus on the droplets that you'll be emitting. So far the evidence
over whether face masks are helpful or harmful is equivocal, difficult to interpret because it
seems to have two opposite or contradictory meanings. Based on current evidence, Professor West
feels we cannot say whether mask wearing is beneficial. Some evidence suggests that wearing
masks can prevent the disease spreading and some suggest the opposite. There may be reasons why
wearing masks could actually increase the spread of coronavirus. However, for some people,
it stands to reason that masks are beneficial, meaning it is obviously true from the facts.
Actually, the evidence is far from obvious, but everyone has an opinion on the issue and after
weeks of stressful lockdown, this can lead to heated debate, discussion or argument in which people
become angry and excited. Up until recently, the World Health Organization said there were two
groups who definitely should wear masks, people showing symptoms of the virus and their carers.
But that left the problem of people who have the virus without knowing it and maybe unintentionally
emitting it, sending something out into the air, for example a noise or smell or in this case
coronavirus. In June, the WHO advice changed. Now they say masks should be worn in public where
social distancing measures are not possible. But the advantages of wearing masks might be outweighed
by other considerations as Professor West explains. It could also have unfortunate negative
consequences in terms of the sort of mask shaming that people feel compelled to wear masks in
situations where it's actually not helpful and maybe harmful because it's expected of them
and they feel that they would be judged if they didn't. But I think in addition to that,
one of the problems we have is that masks can potentially create a false sense of security.
One negative effect is the practice of mask shaming, criticising or humiliating someone for not
wearing a face covering. Another problem is that wearing masks might create a false sense of
security, a feeling of being safer and you really are. Is that what happened in 1905 Rob?
Oh yes, today's quiz question. I asked you when face masks were first widely used.
And I said B, 1905 in Chicago. Ah, well done Sam, you were absolutely right. It was 1905 in Chicago
when Dr Alice Hamilton first noticed that care as wearing masks to treat scarlet fever patients
did not get sick. Okay, interesting. So today we've been discussing whether wearing masks helps
prevent infected people emitting or sending out coronavirus. Well, so far the evidence is
equivocal, unclear because it seems contradictory. In other words, we can't say either way for certain.
But for some, it stands to reason, meaning it's obviously true that mask wearing is a good idea.
The disagreement over wearing face coverings has started heated debate. That's discussion
which becomes angry or excited. And this in turn has led to incidents of mask shaming,
criticising or mocking people for not wearing a face mask. A final drawback is that masks might give
the wearer a false sense of security. That's belief that they are safe when they're not.
And that's all we've got time for today. Bye for now. Bye bye.